así es como suena una onda de sonido
pero cómo se ve esa onda bueno el aire
en el cual está viajando luce algo así
pero si quieren otra representación
visual de una onda de sonido podemos
conectar esta bocina a un osciloscopio y
veremos esta gráfica decimos que esta
forma representa una onda de sonido
porque si nos enfocamos en una sola
molécula de aire veremos que se mueve
adelante y atrás justo como una gráfica
de seno o de coseno aquí el eje
horizontal representa el tiempo y el eje
vertical representa el desplazamiento de
una molécula de aire
conforme oscila hacia adelante y hacia
atrás esta línea central representa la
posición de equilibrio o la posición sin
perturbar de esta molécula de aire si
subimos el volumen veremos que la
oscilación se vuelve más grande
y el sonido se vuelve más alto el
desplazamiento máximo de la molécula de
aire a partir de su posición sin
perturbación se le conoce como amplitud
tengan cuidado la amplitud no es el
desplazamiento total de esta molécula de
aire es únicamente el desplazamiento
máximo medido a partir de su posición de
equilibrio otro concepto clave es el
periodo de la onda de sonido el periodo
se define como el tiempo que toma a una
partícula de aire moverse por completo
adelante y hacia atrás una vez le
llamamos a este movimiento adelante y
hacia atrás como ciclo y el periodo se
mide en segundos así que el periodo es
el número de segundos que le toma a una
partícula de aire completar un ciclo y
usamos la letra t mayúscula para
representar el periodo si decremento mos
el período
y el tiempo que le lleva a la molécula
de aire moverse adelante y hacia atrás
un ciclo completo y el tono del sonido
va a cambiar mientras menos tiempo le
tome a la molécula de aire oscilar
adelante y atrás nosotros escucharemos
una nota más alta
una idea íntimamente relacionada con el
periodo es la frecuencia la frecuencia
se define como uno entre el periodo y
como el periodo es el número de segundos
por oscilación la frecuencia a base del
número de oscilaciones por segundo la
frecuencia tiene unidades de 1 / segundo
y le llamamos 1 / segundo un hertz tiene
frecuencias de cientos o incluso miles
de hertz por ejemplo esta nota
estaba ocasionando que el aire se mueva
hacia adelante y hacia atrás 440 ciclos
por segundo así que la frecuencia de
esta nota es de 440 hertz notas más
altas tienen frecuencias más altas y
notas bajas tienen frecuencias bajas los
humanos pueden escuchar notas tan bajas
como de 20 hertz
y tan alta es como de 20.000 hertz
pero si una bocina hace que el aire
oscile hacia adelante y hacia atrás más
de 20.000 veces por segundo va a crear
ondas de sonido pero que no vamos a
poder percibir por ejemplo esta bocina
sigue emitiendo una nota
pero no podemos escucharla pero un perro
sí podría escucharla los perros pueden
escuchar frecuencias de hasta 40.000
hertz y otro concepto clave con las
ondas de sonido es la longitud de onda
de la onda de sonido la idea de una
longitud de onda es que cuando el sonido
está viajando a través de una región de
aire las moléculas de aire se van a
comprimir juntas en ciertas regiones y
se van a separar entre sí en otras
regiones
si encontramos la distancia entre dos
regiones comprimidas esa será la
longitud de esa onda y ya que la
longitud de onda es una distancia
podemos medirla en metros pero tengan
cuidado es común que algunas personas
confundan la frecuencia con el periodo
el periodo de una onda de sonido es el
tiempo que les lleva a una molécula de
aire oscilar hacia adelante y hacia
atrás una vez la longitud de onda de una
onda de sonido es la distancia entre dos
regiones de aire comprimido las personas
confunden estos términos porque hay una
forma alterna de graficar estas ondas de
sonido consideren esto antes de que la
onda se mueva a través del aire cada
molécula de aire va a tener una posición
sin perturbación a partir de la bocina
que podemos medir en metros este número
representa la posición de equilibrio o
la posición sin perturbar de esa
molécula de aire y conforme la onda de
sonido pasa
por el aire las moléculas de aire se van
a desplazar ligeramente de su posición
de equilibrio así que una gráfica
alternativa que podemos hacer es la del
desplazamiento de la molécula de aire
comparada con la ubicación de equilibrio
o la posición sin perturbación de esa
molécula de aire esta gráfica nos
permite ver para un momento particular
del tiempo que tanto se ha desplazado
esa molécula de aire en esa posición
particular del espacio esta gráfica nos
muestra que en algunas regiones el aire
se desplaza bastante de su posición de
equilibrio y en otras regiones el aire
casi no se desplaza de esta posición de
equilibrio para este tipo de gráficas la
distancia entre picos representa la
longitud de la onda pero no el periodo
ya que estaríamos midiendo la distancia
entre regiones de aire comprimido en el
espacio así que tengan cuidado para una
onda de sonido una gráfica de
desplazamiento contra el tiempo
representa lo que esa molécula de aire
articular realiza en función del tiempo
y en estas gráficas la distancia entre
picos representa el periodo t pero en
una gráfica de desplazamiento
contraposición representa una imagen de
todas las partículas de aire en un
instante particular del tiempo y en este
tipo de gráfica la distancia entre picos
representa la longitud de onda